We've talked before about how during the Obama
Administration, Republican's insisted in baseless
conspiracy theories relating to President
Obama about Obama planning to, or wanting
to, or scheming to stay in power longer than
two presidential terms.
Sometimes it would be Obama's going to declare
martial law to justify suspending the 2016
election.
Sometimes it was Obama's going to change the
constitution so that presidents can have three
terms or unlimited terms or whatever.
And anyone who had a good head on their shoulders
realized that from day one, it was absolutely
ridiculous and completely not based in fact.
But there were lots of Republicans that fell
for that conspiracy just like they fell for
the Trump fomented birther conspiracy theory.
So this unfortunately was a topic of discussion
among certain enclaves of the right while
Barack Obama was president.
Obama will not relinquish power.
He will do everything under the, under the
sun possible, uh, to try to stay in power
beyond 2016.
Of course, it never happened and that was
completely predictable.
Donald Trump, on the other hand, has actually
signaled that he at least has aspirations
to more than two presidential terms.
And Donald Trump also has serious authoritarian
tendencies.
And I'm not going to rehash the full list
of examples here, but lately Donald Trump
keeps quote joking about serving more than
two presidential terms.
And to be clear, I've set up before, I don't
think Donald Trump would get away with it
if he tried, but Donald Trump continues to
reference this idea of staying in power for
more than eight years and over the weekend,
Trump sort of again alluded to this on Twitter,
take a look saying quote apolo should be done
on, which is the more dishonest and deceitful
newspaper, the failing New York Times or the
Amazon lobbyists, Washington Post.
They are both a disgrace to our country, the
enemy of the people, but I just can't seem
to figure out which is worse.
The good news is that at the end of six years
after America has been made great again and
I leave the beautiful White House.
Do you think the people would demand that
I stay longer, keep America great?
Both of these horrible papers, we'll click
quickly, go out of business and be forever
gone.
So by itself, this is like nothing.
It's just another dumb tweet from the president,
sort of alluding to staying longer than eight
years in the White House.
But remember the context.
Remember what Donald Trump said before the
2016 election.
He said he might not accept the results of
the 2016 election if they said that Hillary
Clinton had won.
And by the way, he hasn't accepted the popular
vote results.
He, yes, he did win electorally.
He lost the popular vote badly by more than
any recent president has lost the popular
vote.
And he doesn't accept that he has insisted
that three to 5 million people voted illegally
for Hillary Clinton.
Remember when Donald Trump said last year
behind closed doors to Republican donors that
he likes what the Chinese president has done
saying quote, he's now president for life
president for life.
No, he's great.
And look, he was able to do that.
I think it's great.
Maybe we'll have to give it a shot someday.
Once again, the tendency the appeal to Donald
Trump of the presidency, possibly for him
lasting longer than eight years.
So as crystal is a row in a recent CNN op
Ed, I do not think that Donald Trump is going
to try to change the constitution to stay
in power, uh, beyond two terms.
If he wins reelection, let's not do what Republicans
did under Barack Obama and go crazy with all
of these absurd conspiracy theories.
I do believe that Donald Trump is likely to
question the 2020 results if he loses and
to at least try to make the case that he was
not fairly defeated.
And he's already started to lay the groundwork
for that.
And I do expect Donald Trump to dance around
with the idea if he wins reelection in 2020
that maybe he should remain in power beyond
that.
But I don't think that it's going to succeed
and I don't think that there's going to be
any serious a case that Trump makes that would
actually challenge the sort of framework which
limits presidents to eight years.
Trump, yes.
Is a major authoritarian.
Must get what he wants.
Yes, Trump is the epitome of the sort of entitled
Rich Kid, but is he going to actually try
to forcefully stay in power?
I believe the answer is no and even if he
does there is no way that he could pull it
off even if he actually tries to do that.
The point is if you were one of the people
before 2016 saying that Barack Obama is going
to try to stay in power, how can you not be
saying the same thing about Donald Trump?
Because Donald Trump has actually shown us
that behind the curtain he likes the idea
of more than eight years as president and
he is more than willing to question the validity
and trustworthiness of election results when
the results simply don't suit him as that
entitled Rich Kid that he has been his entire
life.
All I'm saying is there's a double standard
there.
I don't believe that this is a real risk that
Donald Trump is going to try to carry out.